welcome to this video this is something
out of the ordinary I'm doing a couple
of a bonus videos yeah for Christmas
time I know it's a couple of days but I
know that you enjoyed it a lot that I
did some kibbutz ink videos around
Christmas time and not doing a little
bit of that now and those days leading
to Christmas this is obviously on the
ISS see you know the the picture here
just like one of my cats videos but i'm
going to kibbutz this time and this is a
game that I have chosen start with this
is some grandmas goldmund with why this
is some examine rustem of playing with
whitey against German attetion rasta
Matthias Mueller swap one of my frequent
opponents I also played don't go berserk
horse and he just has won the game we
came a little bit a little bit later
let's see what game some we are able to
to catch I'm going to switch around a
little bit and see what's going on this
is a game between the player netherland
with white no name I guess no against my
last row is car this is an i am alex a
cutie f cured a half i'm sorry i had
played him before I think whether with
the wind reasonably so let's see what
happens here we got an got an end game
where the black side is more active fair
he manages to enter with the rook but he
has to be careful the rook on d 2 is now
trapped king of to King III and the look
is gone yeah I just takes e4 and King
III now c 3 has covered the rook okay I
don't understand that actually why is
white using just one minute after 25
move this is just not good yeah instead
of if you here see for you just be takes
e4 and black resins King you three next
move but I don't know why you have to
play immediately I have no idea why ok
now black is just better he can even try
to invade can
take d3 now as well and free the Rope
King c5 King before and that's it I
would black is also playing in San moose
it's not a bullet game guys ok yeah
black should win I will stay on this
game until it is finished even if some
other game has started that is maybe
more interesting on paper but we want to
have somewhat complete games yeah here
black has this three pawns on the
queenside and it's just much much
quicker but for some reason they keep on
doing my bullet game like it could take
some time and and just win the game but
I don't know yeah he probably can just
push the pawns it's maybe a case where
you don't need to be that precise a4 be
30 they just stay just do them to the
homerun hear them spawns white forfeits
due to disconnection yeah kind of fits
yeah I don't know kind of a funny game
ok let's switch to another one we have a
game here white have gained you've asked
you cough legend during Grandmaster from
from Russia his um I looked it up he's
81 years old so the white player here 81
and goldmund Grandmaster rustamov plane
playing black yeah Muslim I was really
strong Grandmaster he was around 2,600
for a long time I think he lost some
points but still a really really good
player let's see black here has I think
the better end game he has some play
along the sea far but white might get
the night to deform what's problem is
his bad pieces yeah he's got this bad
night which is sort of running around
and I won't be too and yeah if white had
the knight on d4 already at the f3
knight it would be nice but he doesn't
manage yeah like now we'll play knight
c6 maybe all night f5 or just rook c8
and 94 96 I'm sorry yeah maybe 83 now
him does this make some sense yeah using
the rook here on this initial square
like yeah maybe and now but now it takes
and look at eight seven looks good rook
t 894 maybe you buy this better here
yeah this is wasn't this wasn't such a
great development in forum for black why
definitely has has gained in the last
couple of news done 94 and looks very
natural looking at c6f5 so that the
Black Knight cannot activate itself yeah
no 96 and you don't go anywhere with the
knight on f3 hmm get out 90 force better
it looked very natural but still night
d3si five those kind of ideas it looks
like white still enjoys some advantage
you know can also play Rukia a one first
yeah yeah someone is committing this guy
beat X world champions in the old days
that's true yeah rustic off was a super
strong GM when he was some in his some
yeah thirties forties and so on he also
i think was very successful in blitz
chess winning the things like the moscow
blitz championships and I can totally
assure you that the Moscow blitz
championships it's a very very strong
event and this is probably tougher then
I don't know some some national
championships or European blitz or
whatever if this ever existed yeah White
has a nice space advantage he has a fire
securely covered with nights on d3 and
f3 it's not easy to make progress I know
that was you cause problem here in blitz
is his time
I'm not sure if I played him before on
video maybe I know that I had one game
where I was some was totally I was
losing and I only really could offer
draw it was heartbreaking i was totally
losing but he was so slow that he
couldn't make it i really didn't want to
want to win on time against him in a
debt position yeah why just trying to do
something on the Kings side interesting
jegs at age five maybe it's just
something for black hmm h5 for the for
the passer White has no problems yeah I
don't believe that but how do you
94 is not helping back to back back back
to age one maybe an ague cage one oh wow
wow Mia this guy can play some chess
Bishop takes is 694 is very strong very
strong move rookie of three king of
three bishops ecigs Luke a7 shakes also
very strong note that the night is
always just winning the beep horn yeah
if rook saturated so Luca a7 i think was
even stronger checking like and
basically forcing black to go back to
the eighth-ranked and maybe then King
III but y de certeau can't in total
control right Kenya taken just take
before I think the h-bond but Luke a7
come on this must be good okay scanning
rupee 7 you can trade and maybe maybe
just Knight to f4 wow yeah 81 years
that's for Chester Chesson and fearful
for all people you know this is really
really strong stuff he just is totally
totally beating black black player here
King you three and you're you're right
King III f form and right on time to
stop the h-bomb yeah this is completely
winning king g 4 h3 and you pick it up
here maybe not take it for allowing King
f5 maybe you can--yeah you can first do
that maybe night f4 check first and then
take it this is total domination yeah
that this resins time almost I can shake
an f1 now and then c3 or something just
securing the pawns yeah or two what two
just like this is your three pawns in
the end game c5
and King edge for finally it's only a
matter of time at least last your coffee
has a guaranteed draw because you can
take e cigs all the time but I hope you
will manage this after really playing a
fantastic game you completely outplayed
rooster mafia best is probably f4 at
five to make sure that this part is
really going away and then you have the
drawing hand and continue from there but
you can just promote here right night x
is 60 even on 96 check system now that
that sets the quickest way very nice
very nice young this is probably some
force check made already black cannot
stop the pawns from promoting c7 c8 flex
king is in a cage it's made in three or
something like that or maybe four moves
enough only thing is stale media that
you had you must avoid check Oh
checkmate it's made a managed yeah
fantastic effort by vashiak coffea
fantastic yeah winning this game against
super strong GM here rustamov was also a
really really really good blitz playa
fantastic stuff okay let's see if
there's more games iam I can switch to a
game here between Daniel Wyatt this is
some Daniel narrowed its key one of the
promising American Juniors I think he's
like 18 or 19 years old and he's playing
YT and a three minute blitz game against
ram master red white I don't know who
that is let me check I've Guinea
thomashefsky very strong very strong GM
thomashefsky is a two thousand seven
hundred grand master for years he won
the european championships only recently
only recently
only way ahead can it's probably a
couple of years ago but he won this
tournament they both are rated 3,000
3,000 something here in none in the
three-minute blitz rating this is not
the Blitz five minutes poor rating that
I have yeah it's a it's a different
different animal in this challenge type
system the ratings are much much higher
which yeah one reason is that this was
the first in frustrating introduced on
icc and some others rating inflation is
this even is even more pronounced them
yeah what kind of positions this is a
carol con and um a typical position for
the old main line of the Bishop f5 Carol
where black is suffering from a
disadvantage in space why does just
place before which is very aggressive
stuff and G form yeah note that this is
three minute yeah very important three
minute without no it's three it's 30
yeah so um we are talking about
something that is some somewhat between
yeah regular five-minute blitz and
bullets s3 mini chess is really a lot
quicker than five minute at Sam it feels
a lot quicker very often just like
bullet says only where you have some
some spots where you can pick to think a
little bit at least yeah black is solid
as mentioned but he suffers from lack of
space maybe you look T for now look you
won this kind of moves to improve
White's position why does just a little
bit better one point is that this black
king site majority is not doing very
much or we could just take the pawn I
didn't even see that I have six however
huh how do you keep your bishop there on
g7 that looks tricky
maybe you have two mil you can somehow
get rid of their for Queen something
like 22 or 24 something like that trying
to get rid of the Queen on air for so
that you can take h6 something like that
is probably probably necessary yeah why
does taking a long time him for a three
minute game 25 seconds now 30 seconds
different is a lot yeah one of the moves
I suggested so probably yeah my
suggestion wasn't totally off wyd
managed to get to to get this Bishop out
but this was definitely not a
development that he generally like to do
Quincy to and now Bishop Bishop back are
then aged five drops hmm root g1s also
may be possible dg1 counter-attacking
Yahiro page 5 and black Aza is a pawn up
and I guess yeah just purely at
arithmetic Lee speaking black as a pawn
up and it looks like there is no
particular compensation especially
considering that White's King position
is really exposed c4b form this is a
very very Airy King and this can be very
problematic as we all know in blood
shall 95 now see if I ever I want to
move oh this is also interesting if
Queen takes e4 21 and 93 both red Knight
c4 was powerful chess with 95 also
certainly was good
yup likes Winningham hmm good move them
just protecting the strong the strong
night and now black can pick up the
piece yeah and now Queens traded so we
have white white resign white can resign
and he did resign yeah okay I guess we
want to see the rematch him and see what
happens yeah now jet ski is black
playing the classical Sicilian with 96
96 and d6 and we got a rouser the rouser
variation after the Russian player to
attention rather age 6 h-6 is uncommon
here 94 Mary is just now a tactic but
black has black has not cancelled so 94
94 Bishop d6 will be a problem I never
saw this this particular this particular
move order for black I really never
never saw that 94 94 bishop age for sd-6
hanging at the end so 90 xe4 cannot be
played this typical tactic that works
very often in the sicilian somehow black
set up is it looks looks problematic to
me I don't know 'if I've looks dangerous
at some point with bishop maybe 24 I'm
actually a bit surprised at thomashefsky
here played one before he's normally a
default player and i'm not mistaken d 4
+ c for his pro playing close games
mostly and very in there a strong manner
actually Tomashevsky is a player to to
watch if um play see 493 any clothes
term clothes repertoire
but here you played very aggressively
with one e 4g fry em black pictures take
this but Luke jawaniya white is playing
as as aggressively as possible which is
quite often a good policy in in blitz
chess and especially in the Sicilian
where we have this this this double
edged type of positions yeah black will
never ever find a safe spot for the king
there's simply no porn cover so it will
be very difficult to play I think PR
probably 90 x 23 now if you go back v5
were just drop yeah now the rook is
hanging in the corner very nice yeah
Queen g3 probably yeah why does a pawn
down but where is black hiding his King
maybe I don't know and why white has a
strong strong compensation for the pawn
as the King never ever will be safe 94
yeah okay nice technica Queen takes d4
Bishop b5 check very strong and black is
giving up the check the Queen to
consolidate he has the bishop pair as a
compensation and two pawns so two
bishops and two pawns that is actually
quite interesting in it could be quite
okay for black if he gets his pieces
properly coordinated for example it is
very important that there is suspicion
on e6 which is anchored by the pond so
you need them you need them outposts
save positions for your pieces the
bishop on F sorry on e 7 does not have
such an outpost maybe King g7 Bishop f6
okay why does smashing through here
trying to get to to a black skink
entering
probably a good decision the bishop only
six was very strong always sort of tying
the whole position together and this is
not easy to play it or look at the seven
widest actor fear they're from a
material point of view this isn't clear
at all can the position itself is very
difficult to play especially in blitz oh
wow cool tech tech I rookie 7 this rook
f to check and look f3 winning back the
Queen maybe yeah Beca back to keep the
rook f2 IDM alive and the bishop on fa
dis covering yeah I think black and
black at least can give a ton of checks
now just job maybe it's a sad wrong why
it isn't due threatening that much to be
honest rook f4 look at five those kind
of ideas queen bee six maybe our queen
III to attack you six check
hmm you see six falling what the chime
both have 20 seconds yeah 3 with a chest
very very shaky but black has tons of
checks and again before it's protected
yeah it is probably quite ok Ferb like I
can even just just cover yeah exactly
just cover this and everything is
coordinated here maybe the G porn is is
even something that will very wide but
of course you have eight seconds against
ten seconds this is the problem it will
not be decided by purely chess means or
C cherish ok ok ok the pawn shop modes
g1 will happen yeah why'd we lose on
time white resented wise now is lost
with the new queen emerging on the board
ok yet another game this is this is fun
let's see ya water what a sight nine
Bishop c4 i think is even even a movie m
and only then 92 yeah you played that
yeah no 92 this is certainly not bad for
while you're here three pieces out black
is none it is very close though so
probably nothing very serious happening
white may be going for F for even him f4
Knight f3 yeah why not yeah I was just
about to say it's something like that
yeah be should be three that was maybe
c4 so this is sick move kini one was may
be necessary now that that's really
really really ugly for white king on you
one black is attacking of just directly
are not not wasting any time
c5 yeah just good where's the night
going to go we have night somewhere
that's bishop c6 or something 94 hangs
yeah black black just has a good attack
game night at 5pm maybe is this a more
night f5 mmm he went for that threatens
made on g7 and if black takes on III
will recapture with the night white is a
power nap after all sorry we should be
through that squeegees have made of
course totally silly nonsense like h5 I
was an interesting reply just Bishop
takes III now yeah come on this is ok
right Knight takes a but still h5 hangs
am not easy Quincy 7
who technically very tricky position
green cakes why it still has a wide open
King position very very problematic but
maybe it's not that bad can you play
maybe just c3 here yeah I now see three
yes it's very possible the Queen I text
the night on age five and the only big
problem is that the night only seven is
stranded this is why I wanted to go d 4
immediately but it's not clear maybe
white can play a lot so f5 very
difficult position there's also the dead
bishop on a two there are many things
that point to to a white to talk to a
problem for wired yeah he has a pawn and
the center and everything but the seven
is stranded H was a bad bad bishop and
you like a little bit of time to
coordinate yeah look aea Jeff and this
thing is lost still a funny poor
information with all pawns advanced on
the kingside 98 there is no attack
really the problem is that on a to this
Bishop it's not participating at all
this is one problem yeah the main
problem is that white is a piece down
but it does not help that one of the
pieces that you have the bishop is not
playing and the rook on a one is also
not really participating yeah black
might even get an f5 f5 breaks the
position open blankets about 30 seconds
down on the clock though
the idea is to get on Queen D for him
just hoping for this cheap trick check
ya goin going to the long diagonal is a
good idea as black just covering the d4
square and now rook g5 and kf3 as easy
as Jeff get the Queen's often okay why
does still trying to win on time which
is yeah well it's a it's something that
you can I can do in blitz of course even
if you got badly outplayed the whole
game let's see ya rook rook to f1 and
that's it candy nothing that white can
do you can take g5 luca and five and
look everyone yeah or this one yeah can
immediately go them i was a swather
hello major open a eight yeah bouquet a
checkmate was a threat but Tomashevsky
saw that again some tricks but you just
take everything and now who get one is
okay check loading yeah Black has 12
seconds it should be Kat should be
enough ready even with some check check
yeah I get near the king and try to get
a check made in check ruge f6f this
looks good even insects six seconds it
should be enough Queen takes b6 and then
check on the back rank this is also good
mate next move hey here we go yeah well
deserves Victoria for Tomashevsky who
really was better from the from the
get-go yeah I keep an eye on other games
but this is really the best of the best
setup you well know dis key is to 6 30
maybe or something and thomashefsky 2730
so it's really high profile match up ok
so this is a sideline
okay interesting yeah a sideline wear
black has accepted a completely wrecked
porn structure but he has got the bishop
Pam and some central play here Bishop f5
looks like I don't know strange move
it's not really doing anything when I
five I was looking at the d3 porn but
maybe you had to know no better
placement for this Bishop that's
certainly possible check like it's
actually allowing trades or encouraging
traits that surprises me even night a
force a move now we're trying to just
take c5 how is he protecting that you
know why by Bishop f5 looked a little
bit strange to me it's doing nothing
there it looks at a protected d3 porn
and it's doing nothing I mean I don't
know where it should go instead but this
is definitely excellent for white but
Bishop Adria this may be a problem so we
are queen e r3 is probably a good news
just covering age three and here yeah
the Queen traders of course would be
fantastic for white and it's hard to not
yeah you can go back but 95 it's just
good for white I think 97 is a huge
threat why does a pawn up and hence
compensation this is something that will
prove to be very difficult for for black
to handle
yeah what a position Y term can pile up
on the e porn now black ass trying them
get a desperate counter-attack with f5
and so on but it shouldn't really be
that dangerous and you can always put
the Queen on f3 and protect things yeah
trading Jesus just the same as resigning
basically yeah but black he didn't
really have much choice what can just
take six and then night f4 no better not
neither for him okay why does try to do
it with trail jack interesting I mean he
is already a pawn up and has the better
structure so maybe trading isn't isn't
the worst possible idea yeah again Trey
Trey 28 pawn up better structure why not
go into the chat rook endgame yeah black
is avoiding that probably wise wise
decision the rook was hanging a large e5
didn't help and I think why this plane
is really nicely he has everything under
control Luke takes f4 is a little trick
now for Luke g1 check this is action hit
Ricky what should one do now he gave up
rook takes f4 is still possible what is
shame here what a shame white got
totally out a black got totally
outplayed and now for some reason he has
one appease them not as kind of a
frustrating game it was totally
one-sided and ya know black black is a
piece up well it's not easier though the
six bonus is falling and active rook and
so on that's not totally easy
check check nice but he does not have to
take kinky one do something I take some
before takes on a two yeah okay why does
trying to do something with his pawns he
has to has to hope for mistakes being a
piece down check which of course was
like I wasn't really necessary at all
yeah why it was completely winning
initially check yeah but she is
continuing in but yes no time to resign
cat so he just continues to fight a
sheriff I've know that that's resins
White Rose I yeah bit of a shame bit of
a shame because it was a very one-sided
game and then thomashefsky just
blundered stuff okay the Reggie here
with CE 4d 4b for Bishop g4 94 like a
trump with a couple of extra moves
Bishop g4 some somewhat irregular Queen
B 7 okay this is a gambit here finally a
queen bee 3f 3b 7 but black be a black
has active play and no doubt about it
he's got the night and play the bishop
fa didn't play even from its original
square and he threatens a text before
yeah and this looks this looks really
tricky why it's a position with no
development here not easy you move like
efore come into consideration trying to
trap the Queen not sure if you manage
that but yeah it was before its
aggressive
Quincy 6 hmm where's the Queen going
here actually maybe now you can take
here yeah exactly but ok Knight takes a
knight takes mmm threatening look a 8
now winning the Queen how do you how do
you save it huh Queen a for Queen a 4
there's lots of stuff like Queen f6 year
how do you protect f2 not at all I guess
had this at Queen a joint like wins yeah
I mean we wouldn't our disk Aditya was
really cheeky moving only pawns and then
his Queen a ton of times he got
completely check completely crushed here
so time for time for vengeance here
Tomashevsky who was winning hit totally
in the game before that but maybe you
can try to get a win in how is their
score by the way there is no no match
score here visible it is slight it's
plus 14 plus a plus 1 is a plus 1 i'm
sorry i have to look it up from let me
look it up from Tomashevsky sper
spective he's on minus 1 so much chefs
key with the win yes black could
actually level the scores and he will
probably do it he is an exchange up and
now a second exchange if he just takes a
one and he has a meeting attack and
that's really a lot on at the same time
yeah that that's it's almost yeah so
impossible to spoil actually can also
take f1 Queen takes for Queen text III
check hiya those those kind of moves
like a nightly resign so there aren't
even score fifty percent and against
Tomashevsky is going for a four hmm
maybe I missed something here and he has
changed his repertoire but he was really
playing mostly see for ID for when I
studied his games he played a sideline
here the g3 line against to e3 this also
had been played by world champion magnus
carlsen in match game I think for it was
against him Arnold I didn't get anywhere
in this game probably also it's not
exactly showing that white has an
advantage g3 is not the kind of move
talking about g3 here not the kind of
move that sees you playing for big edges
white very difficult anyway in modern
chest to get any advantage with white so
quite often people are content was just
getting a playable position and go from
here yeah let's have a look Black has
good center and white has some
weaknesses like FY h 4 and so on
looks looks good for black rabbit maybe
maybe 95 now is good attacking g66 and
UNITA five mukhi five is quite active Oh
interesting what about this year I just
wanted to say night before interesting a
three and where do you go okay I think
black has to probably play some sort of
counter check here like Bishop g6 or f6
or stuff like that
hmm if the night moves he is toast on b7
simply or 96 96 wins they exchange
walking both rooks black has no move
here check their King takes f7 there's
also Bishop g5 check in the mix I mean
white will take first on before he has
to cover d5 or secure d5 and then there
is this chick coming plus wide as a pawn
up so really really a problem I am not
sure what you should play okay flex king
is very weak and who is this Bishop
coughing actually maybe you can do
something yeah exactly yeah yeah for
Bishop d1 Creed III check king g5 Queen
f5 checking age for Queen a five-night
resign yeah resign so this was a nice
win again for Tomashevsky so what is
this is c plus 1 now here and this in
this match yes he turned the table and
he had a totally winning position before
that so he really AM was dominating this
this matchup okay this was nice but no
disk he has disconnected so we have to
look for another game what about blitz
games
five-minute games let's have a look
something good going on three minute are
we actually have heavy hotbird three
minutes he's playing three minute and
against chest Dennis here from Denmark
yah yah dwell dramas Eric LeBron let's
see he's got what is this equal material
Black has nicely centralized pieces
though should be seven Bishop d6
pointing towards the Kings side yeah not
a position you love to have against
LeBron who's such a dangerous attacking
player when it especially when it comes
to attacking your king position yeah i
mean is also good protecting anyway on
the port but against the king it gets
really really nasty often okay he's
black now what is should he do rupee aid
an IG hive would be nice but at the
moment is this blunders due to taking
and queen 87 yeah maybe this g6 move I
was thinking about that just trying to
keep things under control well that
Queen age 7 is not coming and yeah it's
a white is a little bit misplaced the
bishop on a5 is somewhat disconnected
from the rest of his army indira to
decides to be treated maybe 95 now
asking white what is he doing Addison
idea exactly if you trade quit takes
then queen g2 mate is very very strong
this idea okay and now we have to go f4
am very ugly move and just back probably
Queenie 74 Bishop before something like
that yeah or C for Bishop c5 is also
good yeah c4 looks good this would be my
move here
yeah Yardbird is almost 40 seconds up
now on the clock now it is 40 seconds
plus the position i think c4 and he
probably oh no he does not do it okay
yeah we can still take and place you for
no he wants to go to the long diagonal
oh it just hangs on b3 idea i think if
you just take it queen bee three and one
then 27 maybe but Queen txt five what is
this more why can just take the bishop
he didn't what what am I missing I was
just a double blunder and now c4 okay
yeah I understand what what LeBron did
year but it was just blundering on d5
white could have taken this and now we
have now Black is just easily winning he
bought his one apiece and he's got more
than 30 extra seconds on the clock so a
very white resign convincing advantage
that should be enough to to win the game
ok let's see other games going on negm
duels prefer five minute if possible I
here we have another yard game yard but
playing right against geheime bullets I
the secret police grandpa it's I'm is a
GM but US flag many GM's nowadays
impossible to to guess ok a friend once
so yeah bird has played efore against me
he rarely does that I don't know why
he's playing these place diste he plays
d4 mostly
against me we got many limbs or Indians
poor Indian stuff like that okay yeah I
like black here to be honest should be
quite okay hmm the bishop I don't know
should probably go back somewhere on a
three it's not doing anything maybe not
very urgent this this thing but you
never take on before I up and if you're
not doing that what is the bishop doing
on 183 not much black has the two
bishops but they are both not great on
e6 and e7 both not participating very
much in the game interesting what is the
black play up to can play normal moves
like this rook c8 Queen d7 and so on
yeah night to d3 Queen to d3 those kind
of ideas the Queen trade would actually
hmm would it favor black difficult the
same but black probably would not mind
that also i'm thinking if is it possible
wow these 9393 is this what is b3 doing
now this pawn is it just dropping almost
I think it it looks like it's dropping
almost and what is exactly why it sucked
you one maybe two a check on d3 you just
take be tuned for a good position they
are blakiston records in good shape now
yeah III was somewhat yeah somewhat of a
lemon yeah but hmm the night on before
but this 93 ideas was always very
annoying so LeBron went form kicking
kicking the night and it blew up in his
face very uncomfortable now maybe look
c3 or something like that grouped c3
rook takes c3 green c3 very shaky stuff
I rook c8 after Stephen Roxy 81 and then
why does really in bad shape yeah queen
bee 3m he just takes it and now be to
look cb1 les rook takes you three our
queen takes 2-3 and a 3 is also hanging
you cannot even a check here attack the
the Queen rook a to the soup takes you
three back black wins immediately now
that that's that's really bad and black
is two minutes up on the clock yeah a
bad bad beating hear that LeBron
receives pretty pretty tough loss
we don't seem recovering yeah there you
have very little activity as wide very
little and there's queen bee six next
yeah so you have to do something I mean
I don't know what but I think you cannot
attack the Queen in any way and you
cannot prevent the Queen from going to
be six so very tricky black plate this
very fast but I think he could decide on
a number of moves actually while ya know
Braun was using his time a place not
playing she even connected yeah he is
I'm sorry we should be fire maybe just
the full-scale trader look see one would
see one looks the aid just trading
everything that that is possible to
trade
just the sound rook a b1 yep Queen 80
it's not so difficult to black he has
only moves chatter this way you don't
have to decide on very much if you only
have one option
I whoopsie aid it's that's very very
good for black two pawns and no
compensation it is two and a half
minutes up really really really really
am straightforward win for black are
there any other games going on let's
let's check spectacular stuff somewhere
not really yeah black and mostly yeah
you can only lose the game due to some
blunder this position itself is a win
yeah okay maybe night FYI night f 495
some some last-ditch counter check
trying to get at the king I've lost my
fair share of silly games with those
counter-attacks and quite a couple to
yard bird or quincy one quincy and picks
up the night that's it form crazy
counter-attacks yeah he was right now
resides it's absolutely no counter play
or or whatever simply simply a win okay
um what games do we have I'd like to do
one more to make it a one hour video
let's see a little bit more yeah maybe
here Aladdin a versus a crime police I
again Lennon has no name in there but
tons of games yeah I have played both I
believe but I think here geheime for its
I maybe just once or no score zero I
have never played them okay maybe this
guy simply has different playing times
it sometimes happens that you almost
never play
the particular player simply because
he's on that totally different times
yeah the time the time zone some are
crucial yeah okay this was a French
tirage with a very typical structure
their black played 39 f6 this line
leading to this typical on structure
with the default pawn against e6 and t5
and black suffers from the slide from
the slide structural problem but yes
relatively active pc has the f porn are
the f file for his rooks yeah maybe
maybe this is about equal one problem is
that while e6 is technically a weakness
on this half open file it's not really
happening with this weakness because why
it has no pieces whatsoever that might
even come close to put any pressure
there so i think black should be okay we
should be a doll so what's interesting
yeah white now what about taking and f
or something trying to block e five high
he played that also now maybe g3 Bishop
e3 trying to consolidate data white
needs to to finish his build up in a way
ah interesting yeah very good like is
activating his Bishop Bishop c4 maybe
just just putting it down and go and go
from this oh he just took very air um
yeah very radical decision just take
this white has rupee one Bishop g4 and
so on he has some useful pressure
against the porn hmm tricky dropping
back are they repeating mercier are not
going to play a draw here right it would
be a shame just drawing it is an
interesting position and no reason now
okay really no reason for four wide
especially to draw with e6 being under
fire I was surprised that he took on e2
it seemed to me that this night only two
was a really passive piece that is not
easily improved but maybe I'm I'm not
assessing this this correctly black does
not have rupee area this is a this is
one problem here yeah well if you have
to play that something's wrong
something's really really wrong the
night on d 8 yeah maybe he has an active
idea possible like Queen d7 night f7 96
and then to e4 see for but ok he just
drops back no Bishop g4 and what then
maybe cuz ya Quincy five and black has a
problem how can he not trade queens now
Queen d7 floor queen d 7s maybe f5 also
f5 pawn takes rook e7 this kind of thing
and also the queen is on fa de maybe you
can take ecigs just take it six couple
of times we should be 696 rupee 6 okay
White has control he's not rushing
things just slowly building up further
exposition is just entirely passive but
if you don't win e6 immediately then hmm
it's a it's a situation where it is not
so easy to make progress as White's
pieces are already placed so
fantastically you don't really know how
to improve giving up e 6 now check now
you don't want to get rid of the night
on da it but probably you never get
anywhere if you don't take Queen 37
maybe if it's not blundering stuff
that's not even a check so pretty good
nd5 hangs so hmmm not easy maybe Queen a
to queen bee three this kind of thing
yeah it's really good for what he can
maybe just take now only five for
Queenie for check centralizing but it's
not an automatic winner that's not not
trivia or anything check time is equal
both sides about two minutes left
now gently 7 this is interesting a check
it is interesting because blacks King
position is so bad is only eighth rank
and white mmm this winning I think white
has good winning chances his king is
some activated and he's got the very
strong deep on yeah that's a good
decision probably just giving away age
too I think black cannot even take it d
6 now and does
okay then and now d 7 is kini seven so
it's not clear if this is winning so
easily i rue ke samne ka7 winning the
jeep on check and this should win with
the King being maybe not I know King f7
there I didn't didn't think about this
too too clearly as the good drawing
chances him like black has to be ever
get to giving checks from the side I
don't really know how he should win now
and now the King can go to g4 I think he
should have given shakes perform a bit
difficult really difficult to move to
tell King g4 come on kingi form King h4
g4 f5 King edge five and very difficult
not sure if like black hands chances to
defend him not to not sure at all FF
five was good yeah so that you get in
book g6 checking edge right chief or
king age for now just go and so on or
this first ah stronger now h6 faults was
check and that's it white wins so a lead
in here beats the guy I'm pullets I'm
the secret police and yeah this will
also be the end of this um yeah life
kibet sing ok various GM so we've looked
at a couple of GM zia thomashefsky
narrowed it scheme um yeah the
mysterious gallon call it silent era
globe Ron we saw seen a rooster mauve
and Russian chess legend if Kenya wash
your coffee I hope you enjoy to this
cute thing about one hour I will do some
more of those around Christmas time and
the time between Christmas and New
Year's yeah I hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching